what did you say oh do you say only fans
i said shall we do a play watch listen
there are no bad ideas in this
brainstorm i'm
so recording now hold on hold on
i gotta i gotta do no can i have a
chance you saw me
i've been we've been doing a thing i
need five minutes can i have five
minutes yeah you know five minutes
so the only fans i mean this is the
podcast
it's just it's just trying to show
obviously the whole the whole only fans
is just
i think i'm where the money is i feel
like there's an audience
yeah we can vary in it we need to do the
burt reynolds
photo shoot of troy and um and um
that will yeah urban is swinging out of
the gate i like it there's a there's a
crowd that
would invest in any of us like it's fine
there's there's there's people out there
they're apps if it exists somebody will
pay money to see it naked
i like your use of the word it to
describe us
both it places us correctly i think
that's reasonable i think it's fine
i uh considered starting and only fans
just to post pictures of dogs
but be like really explicit to be like
this is just dogs that i saw on the
street
and then like donate all the money to an
animal rescue or something
just just to see what would happen and i
feel like what would happen is that
people would be very upset with me
what you need to do here's the two
suggestions i have
of that excellent idea please tell me
yes number one
really head-scratchingly
odd uh provocative dog poses
where you're like is that it's the ones
where it's the dog's butt and they're
looking back at the camera
yeah where you're like i feel like
that's supposed to be
sort of risque and yet i can't
intellectually argue what makes it that
um and like there's this great family
guy bit where he's at a uh
he's at a like uh like a rooster like a
hen
strip club and and there's a stripper
behind the glass
and peter goes now lay an egg against
the glass and the and the and like an
egg comes out of the hand and shatters
against the glass and he looks
he turns and looks at the camera and
goes i defy you to tell me what's wrong
with this
and i think it's so [ __ ] hilarious so
it's like
so there's that and then part two is of
course you have to
uh then sell bottled dog bath water
uh because that's apparently a thing on
only fans as well
i think only one person did that and but
to the tune of like
millions of dollars which is i think so
i actually don't know how much money she
made and people did try to like
people were on my shelf
oh my god i i did almost uh hose my
my computer with coffee
that was a real that was an earnest near
split
[Laughter]
i do know someone who bought some for
the for the meme which is like how that
that business proposal worked and also
how she became famous
is very specifically by like embracing
meme culture in a way the absurdity of
it yeah yeah absolutely so a lot of
people bought it because it was funny
i don't even but then they were like we
need to do tests to see if it's real
bath water like
it this is false advertising like people
were quite upset about the stupidity i
love
i love the
[Music]
she must have to like change her hygiene
i think she only did it one time when
they all sold out so
oh okay i was like a limited supply i
mean i guess that's the value right
exactly
exactly i i love the idea of the like
toxicology lab getting the call can you
verify the authenticity of this
bathwater
yeah i mean there's an expert there's
one guy in the world who's an expert in
like crime scene bath water
yeah exactly work and he can he can he's
like sherlock holmes he can tell you
exactly like
which shampoo brand was used yep and if
it's dog shampoo
and it incidentally is benedict
cumberbatch
yeah weird coincidence weird coincidence
is a side hustle yeah um
i'm absolutely recording by the way
right now this is all in the show this
is yeah
bath water is in the show but i mean i'm
just honestly i'm just going
to pull the truck i'm just grateful that
troy doesn't have his microphone
on him so we get to kind of
radio mic into a bathroom unfortunately
switch it off just as i walked into
bathroom i realized and switched over
quite often at ign when we be doing live
shows
like there's like several things that
happen but if i'm wearing a dress and i
have a radio mic it's like this terrible
thing of like having to wear a leg strap
sometimes or whatever
but i'd go to the bathroom i would
always disconnect my mic i remembered to
do that but the problem is that i will
still have my ifb in so i can still hear
people talking in my ear
and when you're just peeing and a grown
man is like okay five seconds it's just
very invasive in a way that you've not
like
you i can't really take that out with
like ruining my whole hair and having it
fall off and like screwing the shot for
when i go back and when you come off a
live show
you really don't have long to make that
kind of transition
it's very very strange to be on the
toilet and have someone you know
speaking like right inside of your brain
not much you can do about it turns out i
always thought it would be a really
funny idea
in that vein to have um
like if you if you had reversed a
reversible
me like like uh what's the term one-way
mirror or one-way windows two-way
mirrors what's he like what's the
one-way mirror where like
from one angle it's a mirror from the
other angle it's a window i'm blanking
on the term
um but but you know what i'm talking
about i always thought it'd be funny to
have
that in for a bathroom stalls where it
to you it's a window to everyone else
it's a mirror
so on the toilet you can see everyone
but they can't see you so it's this
oddly like
your brain would be saying i am so
exposed i am so exposed but you're not
and so there's there's a there are
buildings with like urinals up against
windows
that are done like i've i've i've er
oh yeah the the soho house in uh
in uh west hollywood absolutely but it's
it's from the 20th floor or whatever so
it's like you're staring out over los
angeles it's not like you're staring
really
does anyone here ever wanna like a
jumpsuit or a romper
they do have man rompers these days i
mean i can i try and keep my personal
life off
that's right i shouldn't have asked you
that that was invasive i apologize you
can take it to
play watch this in hr after our only
fans conversation we just have
it um no but there's this really funny
thing
where if you're wearing a jumpsuit or a
it would be romper would be probably
more correct i saw someone tweet about
it just yesterday
where you just have to be like
completely naked if you go to like a
public restroom
because you have to take the whole thing
off you take the hole yeah
so you're just sitting there like in a
public restroom like completely naked
just like
okay well nobody could see me but it's
extremely
uncomfortable also in your country the
doors have gaps so this is terrible i
don't know why they i don't understand
i hate it that's mine is that just
something that all americans just
accepted as like
it's terrifying to have again i've made
eye contact with people through this
because of the stroke effect as you walk
if you if you've ever like walked past a
rhythm and like
just automatically just looked around
you because of the strobe effect as you
walk past you see ev
everyone it's horrible don't just
just build doors that fit the holes you
make also less water
why do you why does it have to be so
noisy
why is that to be so wet noisy there's
so much water in american toilets
yeah we like to flush it hard why is
that
are you referring you to tell me what's
wrong with this i
uh we absolutely are recording we are
i'm recording this for sure this is such
a good call time we have
this weird like maybe i need to do that
i don't know i get this weird echo
i am i feel
there we go um that's what it was i'm on
the edge of my seat here
i'm on the edge of my seat i have a
friend of mine
that would always go
not always but on rare occasions if we
were at the movie theater or whatever
and he was a tall fellow she's like
my height if not even taller and you're
what
my height if not even taller just
checking i thought i heard you say
height
and that's one of those weird so here's
okay here's another one that's that's
one of my
weird little triggers yeah it's i
this was an argument that we had on set
of
uncharted 4.
those from texas will often say
height now all right
it is an actual archaic albeit archaic
alana's face accepted version of the
word height
i understand that it's weird i
understand that it's weird
but i was not really made aware of the
uniqueness of that variation
until i was standing in front of
nolan heights look it up
it's an ex someone pointed out that
shakespeare sounds better with an
american accent and
they theorize that that's how they align
with the accent evolved if i said that i
must have said it on the show before
i've heard that
before i do know that like if you if you
go to like uh people in
in like the their carolinas are probably
the closest to the original
um english
whatever the idea is that the english
accent as we know it now
is quite a recent invention and the
rhyme scheme in
shakespeare actually kind of suits an
american accent more in the theory goes
that actually
a lot of the sounds that we associate
with american speech are actually
historically how english was spoken in
the we're the ones who've
changed our accent over time i think
that americans invented that to feel
like they are the true
i think that i think so that sounds that
sounds like us
no klingon of course oh nice reference
i i do think that by the way by the way
austin sorry apologies
star trek we watched we because me and
kerry were really cool we watched every
star trek movie over the weekend
how do you define every like motion
picture
through one to six the original cast the
classics
and i was struck by how
how basically so the movie no one's seen
which is the fifth one where they go and
meet god
mm-hmm is i think bite your tongue what
do you mean no one's seen that
i haven't i
did he do do you know if he did the
score for first contact
he did usually about score
he did more star trek films than any he
basically owns
star trek to the extent that any one
composer does because he did
he did the motion picture he did final
frontier and then he did
first contact insurrection nemesis and
they used his theme for
next generation from motion picture and
he did the same for voyager
so first contact reuses
all this is this is this musical you
wouldn't understand troy this is musical
symbol
i've literally i literally have four
boom it's a reversal i'm talking about
light motifs and you've got books you've
got reversal you know carded hard there
bethel
that's incredible but seriously it's uh
austin
every note of music he wrote you are
playing to me over zoom at some point
we're doing that
or right now first contact he's just
ripping off all his light motifs and
themes from uh five
and he got away with it because no one
watches five except troy
you're saying that the uh
[Music]
that's the theme the first contact the
first half of that is
a recurring theme in five i have to go
back and listen to five because i mean
it basically takes a bunch of bits if
you listen to five all the building
blocks are first contact and of course
you've got the um
the klingon theme
[Music]
but those two tracks that's your first
contract score except for and here we go
that's this is a real test
the borg theme which is uh
it's something like that oh no
he's nearly there he's nearly there but
yeah no seriously because that's the
that's the that's the great that's one
of those great star trek convergence
moments because
in first contact you see the borg cube
being
attacked by all the ships and then the
defiant shows up freshened by
cap captain by or wait no it's not
captained by wharf
uh he takes him by wolf oh okay because
i do know that jerry whips
exactly yeah because he's wool but i
thought it was brilliant i thought it
was worth taking over because
but no it makes sense i have to watch i
think yeah
but seriously austin five and first
contact back to back i think that's a
good watch from a composer point of view
i think
do you know that there there's an easter
egg in that battle scene of all the
federation ships
uh attacking the millennium falcon flies
by in the background fighting the borg
as well
oh it's up there with like the firefly
and battlestar galactica
wait a minute wait a minute how do they
do that
they've they've made a model of the
millennium falcon and they shot it with
a camera
and they made it how did disney shut up
how did disney not sue the or not disney
at that point how how did how did lucas
like
yeah it's very small it's very small and
kind of it's like three pixels
it's not like yeah and it's one of those
things that i suspect it's kind of like
honor amongst thieves of like
they see it as a tip of the hat it's not
a it's not a like we're trafficking in
the popularity of star wars to prop up
star trek
i feel like disney probably would have
done something maybe if if alam even saw
it they might have been like
that's cool well lucas lucasfilm was
pretty litigious the
the um i remember we we did a game
called subsurface circular
where
actually so we we we had those robots
were called droids in early versions and
we were basically told by our lawyers do
not call them droids
that's why they're called texts because
uh lucasfilm has like
they trademarked a lot very early
because battle
battle tech right the car the the
tabletop
game that was called battle droids so i
like that my favorite thing there is
that basically if you've got a game with
droids in it you're gonna end up calling
them texts that's just
that's that's the same thought process i
didn't learn this until much later that
battletech did the exact same thing i
did it seems to be just
you want to know how i cognitive
confluence you wonder how i discovered
what you're saying i was when the um
when razer first started selling
phones and it was the android
like operating system i was i was
watching a tv commercial and i just
happened to glance down at the bottom of
the fine print and it said android
trademark lucasfilm in a commercial for
a phone
and i was like holy [ __ ] they had to
license
androids or droid droids
so they literally licensed that to for
the phone and
and and acknowledged it in the
commercials and i i was like
damn george what watch this damn
george so when we would go
also of course sorry apologies i just
realized ilm was a subsidiary of
lucasfilm right so yeah
they got the million falcon because they
were basically the studio that made that
special effect shot
owned the millennium falcon oh you're
saying that star trek was was
islam also star trek special effects for
that movie oh that makes a lot more
sense then yeah if you're watching a
star trek movie and the special effects
look good it's ilm if not then it's the
people they bring in whenever they've
run out of money
the though you could the the special
effects in any given star trek movie are
directly correlated with the
box office earnings of the previous star
trek that means they already had them
i really thought that was beer when you
first walked in that's tea
well this is tea i told you i upped my
tea game like you really did i have
i have this steeper yeah so like i put
it in this
thing for you know however long it tells
me to do that and then i just set the
cup
i think you showed us this it's pretty
cool it's like a fresh
french press with like a hole in the
bottom yeah yeah and so just like as
soon as it meets that it
pushes a lever and dumps the tee in
there really cool
huh um when i go over to his house he
just microwaves water and hands it to me
with it to be happy
i just like that someone looked at a jug
and was like
wait a minute this isn't liquid just
come out the bottom they've been doing
this wrong
i don't want to literally this one it's
a teapot with a hole in it which is a
metaphor often used for a uselessly
brilliant well wait a minute guys maybe
we've been doing it all wrong
so watch this we would go to someplace
like the movie theater whatever my big
tall friend would stand up at the urinal
and for a joke he would just completely
drop trowel
so that there was an adult man with his
ass hanging
butt naked butt naked his butt everybody
else
and he would do like the whole hands on
hips look ma no you know
while i peed and everything and told me
he's about six four six five i feel like
that adds to it
it does because it means that those
asses are like eye line for other people
yeah and you're used to like me seeing
like a six-year-old or five-year-old do
that but whenever you see a grown man
with his
pants at his ankles and just
uh i think that's hilarious it is a
powerful
every time every time dude it was
awesome i don't see it as a power play i
see it as
i see it no
he's watching this right now you know
i'm talking about you and i love you
enough that i mean i should just just
out you completely
but he is he's he's still one of them
the person we would have heard of is
this like
okay not at all not outing someone as uh
no
um but like you know troy he's
describing himself
he was testing the water just to see how
well it was received what's the reaction
are people gonna be okay with this
i i never had the confidence to be out
that takes supreme confidence that that
gives like i'm
sorry where did i keep all my [ __ ] that
i have to give i have none
um my dad is the guy that would have
done that he might my dad's favorite
thing was farting in public
and and delighting like he he he
zero [ __ ] given one time we were at the
uh we were at the airport
and the denver airport had this like you
would go through security
and then you they had a little tram that
would take you to the terminals because
they were very far from the central hub
where security is because it's i would
love to talk about the denver airport by
the way but go ahead
yeah it goes it's a sprawling massive
complex and so the the uh there's an
escalator that has to go down the
equivalent of
how is that
out for the video games we didn't have a
huge uh news drop this morning at all no
i know we'll get to that we'll get to
that uh
in the spirit of the no [ __ ] given this
was one of these seminal childhood
moments for me where
uh we go through security and then you
have to take this escalator that goes
down the equivalent of like three floors
so it's a long it's an inordinately long
escalator
and um my dad had his carry-on
little roller bag and had a like a coke
can on top
and it was apparently precariously
balanced because as soon as the
we got on the step it it did the slow
motion thing where
it hit the the bladed front edge of the
stair
on the escalator that gave it this pin
prick hole and also sent it like
rolling end over end and it shot all the
way and it was one of those perfect one
in a million things where it was a
crowded escalator but it didn't
hit somebody and stop it managed to hose
like a hundred people with a mist of
sugary sticky coke and like it's going
between people's legs and like it in it
and it was this thing and then it gets
to the bottom and starts
slowly awkwardly pooling because you
know like the moving escalators holding
it in position
as it's sort of rolling so there's this
little pool of coke forming and some
little indignant 10 year old at the
bottom goes
who did this and my dad started jumping
up and down going i did it i did it i
did it
because he thought it was the funniest
thing ever and he was not
going to let someone else take credit
for it and
of course everyone is pissed and he was
just in hysterics and it was like one of
those
little glimpses into what it's like to
just not give a [ __ ]
uh and uh good it's a good moment
that is absurd and i love it um
i'm going to intro the show now
[Music]
i like how i do that with a pause
because i'm scared whenever i do it
someone's going to derail me so
hi everyone i'm alan i'm a video game
writer that's troye baker he's a video
game actor that's mike piffle he's a
video game director and that's austin
wintry he's a video game composer
and we talk about anything other than
video games apparently
um before we get to the biggest news of
the morning which is
uh xbox but those are going through um
can we talk about the denver airport yes
i would
love finally finally someone says what
we're all thinking no really troy what
is it
oh god if you've never been to or just
just google
you know denver area i specifically
asked you
we thought you'd have like some kind of
personalization a lot of this is
what you have to you have to like
see these images but first of all it
it talking about all the like conspiracy
theories totally for an example there's
just some
dude there are some beyond the idea
you're tapping into my childhood here
yeah you talked to you talked to pilots
and it was like
that airport makes no sense whatsoever
there's too many
runways that don't go anywhere they are
laid out incorrectly
um there's a whole like subterranean
network system
that runs underneath it uh it was so
they used that i mean the the
sub the subterranean network is how you
go from terminal to terminal
no this is something different this is
like there's there's like there's a sub
subterranean sub sub sub subreddit it's
where the uh mages
and
uh what's the name of their group in in
um
deus ex where you're you're you're you
nat co and then below
them is the even more conspiracy people
that you like sneak out of and end up
underneath in your own base
it's not even that there are like
conspiracy theories it's just
12. a list for the most
um well-known conspiracy theories how
many are there about this one airport
there's a lot of weird mythology around
this thing also famously when i was they
were completely new to me they were
building it they won't make a video game
the secret tunnels if a masonic tablet
or gargoyles the demonic horse or
tanguma's murals did not indicate the
workings of a secret society or sin of
the coming of an apocalyptic event then
what of it
why pepper dia with them many believe
that the building itself
is a gathering place for governmental
officials and the global elite in case
of nuclear armageddon
so there's all sorts of stuff in denver
but
actually has a lot of that because of
the uh like um what's the what's the
government
um like missile defense program that's
based in that's why they keep whopper
if you've seen
no war games nobody
would you like to play a game same with
uh red dawn right start takes place in
denver or in colorado in the mountains
it's
close to nazi secret societies
horrifying hot ringers of doom
hidden in public artwork everyone claims
that there's a lot of like coded
sort of yeah like sonic temperatures
they're they're
they're all they're wrong about the
debate they're all
they're not even they're hidden it's
like there's just you know inexplicable
like designs put up on walls for no
reason and there's just like you'll see
numbers
and like the whole masonic lodge thing i
don't have any problem with that that's
that's just a lovely dan brown
popularity
i was a barman for the freemasons at one
point great great organization whatever
i i have no idea not so great not if
you're a goat
anyway
[Laughter]
and that's not the way the kids use that
word
um but no th this this uh it is a it is
a
remarkably peculiar airport like i've
i've never also it was like a thousand
percent over budget when they built it i
mean it was one of those it was supposed
to cost like a billion and it costs
something like 10 billion dollars yeah
it says that that's the theoretical
truth here that this is just
the worst is like this there's a show in
the uk which everyone should watch
called um
2012 which is a joke show about the
planning of the olympics it's the idea
of like the worst one kind of like the
office but like
for the people putting together the
london 2012 olympics brilliant
there was a sequel called wma where the
guy in charge gets charged gets
put in charge of the bbc and again just
terrible management
brilliant show this is like that imagine
if you accidentally created a vortex to
hell
or like a space that had all of this
imagery
this is just like a bumbling idiot who's
like accidentally
placing all these masonics this article
it's like that's a good comedy movie i'd
watch that movie
sounds like a spin off of office space
of the uh i believe you hit my
guy this article i found implies that
they
um have started to play into it but uh
this
travel leisure.com says according to
psychology today many people believe
conspiracy theories because of their own
desire for meaning certainty security or
to maintain their own self-image
preach on but absolutely in the case of
the airport
it's all true it's real it says there
have always been quite a few because of
its construction
including why the airport cost so much
more and took more time to build in the
first place so i guess that's the source
of them but i
i generally think that you have to be at
building airports to create an airport
so wrong it becomes a culture you know
what you know what that
taps into that funny enough i was like
wait till we're recording
little behind the scenes on how the show
gets made when you said about conspiracy
theories because you were asking
you said humans are naturally uh pattern
recognizing and and
conspiracy theories are part of that uh
yeah because
there's a it's i think it was michael
shermer that gave a great
um primer on this about uh the nature of
like a type one
cognition error which is basically
there's false positives and there's
false negatives
where if you make a false positive
you know you are you are basically
wrongly attributing
agency to something that is actually
nothing
or the other opposite would be that you
basically mistakenly don't attribute
agency
for which there is something and so
there's a huge huge
evolutionary advantage for false
positives because basically
the these are safe the bushes yeah the
bushes move if it's the wind i'm safe
but if i just assume
it's a tiger then i and i react
accordingly i will live more often than
if i'm like ah it's nothing and then the
tiger jumps out
yeah so we're we're predisposed to find
patterns in everything and to look for
agency that it's the same what's the
term for
uh this when you recognize faces and
things there's a
there's a term there's a there's a
psychological term for that
yeah yeah that and
people will remember in the comments i'm
sure but but uh
that's again that's the same instinct we
we look for patterns and things because
we've been programmed through
many many millions of years of evolution
like my entire job
yeah is to like lead you towards the
thing you're meant to be thinking
and lead you away from all the dumb ass
theories
yeah yeah paradilia okay but is that is
that not
evidence of design grand design well
exactly that's
that's the that's the uh um that's the
uh uh
um uh hitch [ __ ] what's his name why am
i today i'm just all blanks douglas
douglas adams the the pool that the the
puddle i like how you got that based on
him going
you got hitchhiker's guide from and you
went douglas
because we're it's clearly i could say i
recognized the pattern right
there's i used to be able to speak some
klingon
i was really cool wow
i think i actually have conversational
klingon behind me oh my god
in my uh in my if you go on my blog if
you see my
if you see my blog entry about when i
came this close to getting hired
for star trek discovery i hired a choir
to sing in klingon
at the scoring stage it was atrocious
you can hear it
as well do you know do you want to know
my favorite klingon fact yes
do you know those there is a there is a
specific i think it's a
like a transitive tense or something
there's a specific part of the language
that exists
entirely because an actor mess
it was uh christopher lloyd in three ah
exactly yeah that was very good four
right three three is search for spock
yeah four is the voyage home so it'd be
five yeah four is your way
so six is am i wrong undiscovered
country
six years five is five is god god um
terrible movie
but the but christopher lloyd basically
messed up his line and the one that
shatner directed
we should include the worst one is the
one shatner directed yeah
because uh favored nations clause is for
the win
um but the um the uh uh what as i said
christopher lloyd messed up his line and
mark ocran who's the
guy who basically all also got his book
god
what we're learning is that mike
actually really doesn't want to talk
about video games ever and it's out of
courtesy
who invented klingon vulcan i think he
also
worked on lord of the rings on the
elvish language wow
a lot of that was oriented that did that
right it was but there was there was
some stuff they had to
develop i can't remember why like
something about spoken rather than
written
anyway basically uh christopher lee
christopher lloyd sorry
apologized to marco and he's like i've
messed up your line i've messed up your
line
and the director like was liked him
wanted to move on and auckland's like
it's fine i'll change the language
there's an entire
tense within klingon as this made up
language that exists
only because christopher lloyd couldn't
get the phonetic pronunciation correct
and and they've had to work around
that's all that's how we end up with the
words like
yeah all your klingon um opera and your
klingon uh
singers and the shakespearean
translations are all based on
essentially christopher lloyd flopping a
line and the director going
good enough that's cool though um yeah i
love that that's to me right up there
like with him that's a talented
guy as well who can take that and go
with it and make that work
those kinds of impactful in the moment
stories that's to me analogous to
one of the defining moments of the
character of indiana jones is him
pulling out the gun and shooting the big
swordmaster guy and that was entirely
because harrison ford had diarrhea and
couldn't shoot for more than like five
seconds at a time
wow he was wildly ill on set and uh have
you seen
the bonus takes of the whole fight
of that scene like they attempted to do
it yeah there's there's a whole
oh my god that's the book to read anyone
who's interested this isn't by him i
love that you got it three pounds off
too
can you say it out loud for audio
listeners mike
it is um the art of language invention
it's written by the guy who yes you're
reading english we're talking about
speak the weird language do the do that
i don't know i love how that i love that
right yes it says uh i believe if i'm if
my translation is correct this says
antibacterial jerry's like
seriously like the guy this is by the
guy who did dothraki that's where i got
confused so he
like like there's a real like artistry
to um
to creating absolutely on a human level
talking about pattern recognition you
know even if you can't speak a word of a
language
you know a real language from like
gibberish this is why they're
speaking in tongues people are so
obviously faking it uh
like it's a very good it's a very
obvious tale because you're right we can
hear the
that's why i always loved miele
jovovich's like rant in
fifth element when she they first like
3d print her
and she does this explosion of language
that really does
sound like an actual non-earth language
and i always remember thinking
that must be hard to learn as an actor
because you're fighting all of these
instincts that your language has kind of
beaten into you and and now you have to
sort of
step outside that have you ever had that
happen to you where you've forgotten
english for like where you've been sick
or something and english has become
gibberish for you i also can handle
snakes and
not get poisoned i've i've had it i had
it for about two minutes it's the most
terrified i've ever been i was in front
of the tv and everyone on the tv was
speaking gibberish in my brain whatever
part of my
because i imagine your language center
just i was i was sick
and tired and i i it almost sounds like
a very
minor stroke or something that's what i
was going to go with
it was weird and it was like that was a
stroke [ __ ] terrifying
like just like i don't i know they're
speaking this is the new it was like the
news was on or something i was like i
know that guy is on the news
and i couldn't understand it was it was
i was hearing mouth sounds but couldn't
process them as long as
the weirdest thing my my mom's actually
terrified my mom once uh took a
medication she was dealing with
migraines and she took a a medication
that like nothing was working so she
kind of went out on a limb with a
slightly off the beaten path medication
that caused her to have a seizure coke
and uh
she had a she had a seizure which was
dropped from the top of the escalator
hey terrible but good recall um
about the story about your mother having
a seizure i just want to be clear we
laughed all over that that is quite
serious
she's okay now she's okay now it was a
it was a very alarming thing because she
you know it was 20 years ago
i don't know i have migraines and i have
just been recommended
trying cbd oil for it it was definitely
not that i don't know
it was it was like a it was like a
narcotic i mean it was like because her
hers were real bad like debilitating and
uh
so it was and it's something she's dealt
with forever and she but she um
there was definitely this coming out of
the fog period that was very
like had stages and at first she
couldn't remember how to speak
so my dad i remember was sitting with
her sort of because
him being a doctor he i think he
immediately clocked what the signs were
of what was going on
and so he was just sort of trying to be
very calm because you know
imagine the confusion and if someone is
erratically trying to and they're
freaking out talking to you it would
only add to the anxiety so he was very
dispassionate he was always extremely
cool
under pressure anyway being a surgeon i
guess pretty essential
and uh so yeah i remember walking what
is this thing here exactly
yeah the doctor nick style one of my
one of my favorite simpsons bits ever of
going
going under right as dr nick goes what
the hell is that
uh yeah but uh yeah so uh
yeah remember she she regained the
ability to speak before her memories
were fully intact because i remember she
did not know who anybody was and she
knew she should know
but i remember my sister walks in the
room and she was like
i know i should know who you are like it
was one of those really weird middle
zones where you've got part of the
apparel
apparatus working again and then the
other half is just not there
i have a question it's just me computer
i have a question first it's scary oh go
go along please
troy have you ever had to speak a
different language for a role
yes and any made-up ones oh yeah
how's that how does it work for you oh
powerfully yeah the entirety prophets
right
dude there's well that was all written
out and to his credit he wrote that
language
like he could tell me exactly what it
was that we were saying
um oh dude this is going to get real
interesting
so um growing up the way that i do
business points if you can incorporate
the bathroom guy with
with the you know actually in some ways
but don't but don't reveal to us
one person in the story that troy's
about to tell is the bathroom
yeah he's not going to tell you which
one yeah
one person you're right yeah you don't
want to this will shock you
the growing up the way that i did i was
exposed to i grew up in the height of
the what was called the charismatic
movement of the 80s this is when
churches moved out of the traditional um
and into the contemporary so it was now
we got electric guitars up on stage and
we've got people with tambourines and
streamers and people are dancing people
are speaking in tongues
even though the speaking in tongues
thing actually dates to like early 20th
centuries like 1908
i think is when that that kind of like
became popular became
the pentecostal revolution um it was the
cinema of its day
it was it was the
fellini they knew nothing about so
the i love the runway that you need for
this story
i want to lay proper tarmac for this so
that that was kind of like
with the masonic temple this was the
best of times it was all happened
underground the denver airport i'm
telling you guys i've seen some lizard
can you people if this is the best or
the worst one of these we've done
i i wasn't really
it was the worst of us
i i i could create um i didn't have a
lot of toys and so the ones that i did i
had to do a lot with
and so i didn't have like the big
transformers playset i would have
one gobot so i had to create worlds and
i had to create characters and i think
that's by and large where i got
i was able to to use that part of my
imagination to be able to
turn that into a career so being able to
and i would do the voices for all my
different gi joes or transformers or
whatever it was that i had
um and so being able to
create a language or be able to create
different sounds for me came
i don't know naturally but it wasn't
that i had a proclivity at least towards
growing up the way that i did it was
that speaking in tongues thing was
very prevalent in in my growing up and
in the church
that that i grew up in so i was used to
kind of hearing and every but what's
interesting is
everybody has their own specific take on
it everyone has and you will notice
these kind of like
repetition of patterns syllables
consonant sounds that kind of thing
um so the
the the ability to mimic
voices and like what mike was talking
about earlier
being able to absorb that and be able to
kind of like
adapt to that was something that i had
as well so being able to create a
language
was something that i would do i would
also fake being able to
you know if i if i understood the accent
of french i could fake the words
and i could fake spanish or whatever so
yeah a lot of times like
even in um for young justice like
markovian is a completely made-up
language
but it's something that would be they
were very cool about they're like what's
most important
is that there's not a lexicon that you
need to follow it's
understand the intent and if you flub
some syllables or whatever
it's more about the performance than it
is the phonetics um
so yeah i've had to do that a lot and
it's it's something that
can trip you up laura bailey was she
speaks simesh
like she had to learn or semlish i think
is what it's actually called
yeah so she has joyce yeah so she had to
do that and she was like
that is a language is she the sims
voices
she was for the longest time i was going
to others i thought that
was just like kind of phonetic guesses
and not an actual language
it is a language like there is there's
like specific like
words and structures
i wonder if that is translated because
that like you can watch her do that and
she's clearly reading it
but it does sound similar enough to the
actual song and i never considered that
they would be one-to-one translated
yeah it's hard we did that on tooth and
tail also
uh the the the kind of we wanted to make
something that sounded very
slavic and very sort of russian
but is its own it's its own uh this is
the book on how to do that you can't you
can't invoke
the same book twice that's not bethelian
fine i'll find the
conversation i'm clearly interested in
that book it's a really good book yeah
i'll share with you
i i the question i was going to ask if i
may um
alana for you we discussed like a couple
weeks ago
about um alternative medicines or
whatever and then you you mentioned cbd
oil
if if you had i've never had a migraine
to my knowledge i've had a migraine i've
had severe headaches but as i understand
there's something completely different
and i i don't like when people go oh
i've got a migraine it's like no no no
no no when i get migraines and it
happens
probably once a month or so it is
shaking
um being in a dark room and trying
desperately not to vomit
and i would say probably 80 of the time
i vomit so the issue with having a
migraine is not like oh i have a bird
headache it is debilitating
vomiting like i will be shaking like
this i will hit my own head repeatedly
to like try to like get rid of this
awful pain
but you can't do anything and the
biggest issue that i have with with
having migraines
is you don't know when they're gonna
happen and they will wipe you out for
eight hours and then you're just fine
but for that eight hours it's like i
can't work i can't do anything i can't
go anywhere i can't even look at my
phone sometimes to communicate that i
can't do anything it like
fully [ __ ] you up for one day no
control over it and i'm like it's it's
the most infuriating thing because like
i've had to miss things
by having a migraine i'm just like i
just have to sit here and try not to
vomit and cry for [ __ ] eight hours
they're so bad and as i understand the
cause of them
is is it's not like oh i had too much
caffeine or whatever it's
the cause of it is a completely
different thing i had a friend who had
migraines and he knew
like all of a sudden if he got this one
warning sign he goes i have 18 minutes
i think my warning sign is my eyes
stinging but i'm not positive
oh interesting so that's the thing that
you have to figure out yeah you have to
figure it out over a really long plan of
time
patterns again like figure out what it
is that's causing your migraines because
for everyone it's different i think mine
comes
if my eyes are stinging the night before
then i will have a migraine the next day
but i'm not positive about that yet i'm
still trying
it's not even like oh i need to stop
doing this is like no this is going to
happen
he would be like he would literally
stand up for work and leave drive home
and he was like i have
i have to get home in 12 minutes or i
will not have any vision left
and that friend was the bathroom guy
that's that that's it really
but yeah but if there's one hobby you
don't want to develop as someone who can
be debilitating
at any time inside the places
that seems like a terrible idea if if
you could go to acupuncturist
and they're like we have found that this
specific you put it you put a little pin
here and your big toe
or whatever it would be it's never in
the place that you would think it was
it's never going to be in your head
it's going to be as like oh yeah give me
your left pinky yeah and we're going to
put a pin there
and it assuaged it what does that mean
what do you does that mean like because
we talked about like medicine
is like basically alana the
neuroscientist
is being asked a question no i don't
know what that means no i'm just
i'm saying like does it matter like it's
and the same thing if if someone said
you go
to that mountain i don't care what gets
rid of it just get rid of it as long as
it's not like heroin
but yeah if someone's like i'm gonna put
a needle in your foot and it's gonna get
rid of i'll be like cool get rid of it
i'm just going to jump in with one thing
because i am like you know the
aggressively empty
alternative medicine so i'll say my
piece and i'll go i want to quote the
animation that austin mentioned earlier
which is stormed by tim mentioned and
the best line in that and
the best line in that whole thing is
there is a word
for alternative medicines that have been
proven
to work and it's called medicine
medicine
what you're saying if the african
puncher says we have found this to work
on this
if that were true if if science had
found
that there was any correlation between
sticking needles in people it's just a
matter you just get that in the er
like it would just be part of the
process the reason it's not
is because it's bollocks and has been
proven scientifically to not have an
effect
except for placebo beyond placebo of
course that's what i was just about to
add is that there there is
placebo will always have an impact yeah
yeah like if you
feel like you're proactively doing
something to help and you're
calming down or like perfect example is
um
uh there was a story in i think chile
of the miners uh trapped in a
mine and in and they're you know waiting
to be rescued and
it's like if everybody stops and prays
for rescue
um they're consuming less oxygen they're
a lot calmer
there's a lot of second order effects
that the prayer
actually helps facilitate but you can't
there have been scientific studies that
have implied that prayer for the exact
reason you say
actually does technically work in terms
of
whatever though it's just it's a short
hand for that thing any level of belief
if you believe in something then that
can help you
but yeah like i think it's even the
example used in storm is
paracetamol it's just a leaf essentially
is where they found the chemical it was
a
thing they found in the woods and people
would eat it and they'd notice that
their headaches would go away
and that is ridiculous and if that was
something i said to you
there's this there's this leaf you guys
have got to try chewing on because
it removes headaches you'd laugh at me
and say that was ridiculous
and most people did well the ones that
had your attitude the scientist troy
they went and they tested it and they
realized oh [ __ ] this actually works
we can make this and more importantly we
can sell this
and that's what happens to any medicine
that actually works is it's
is humanity incorporates it into our
medicinal
kind of processes but that isn't i don't
think that that all medicine is a pill
right no of course no there's plenty of
medicines well you can't with a migraine
because i will just vomit it up it does
that does not work
so yeah there's plenty of medicines like
i mean like uh [ __ ]
physiotherapy is a medicine right but
that's you know because that has been
proven through scientific process to
work that's provided as a real medical
does that mean that if i say that one of
the only things that helps me with a
migraine is sleep and that's only if i
can fall asleep if it's
not bad enough that sleep in that case
is a medicine
it's a treatment i would call it i feel
like that's more your body heals itself
we can help i would say your body's
natural healing factor
to use [ __ ] wolverine because i know
what kind of podcast i'm on
like your your natural healing factor
wouldn't be
medicine per se but it's part of your
process and most medicines actually work
in tandem
with your own inherent your body wants
to survive so therefore
sorry your body has through evolution
developed procedures and processes and
chemical reactions which
encourage you to survive the body
doesn't want anything um
so yeah most so sleep probably isn't a
medicine but like
you choosing to go to sleep is arguably
a medicine yeah that's
you know yeah troy i feel like you've
been trying to say something for ages
sorry sorry no no no
it's it's i've never looked at it
differently so here's here's my position
and i can be
unashamed about this i grew up again
we're talking a lot about my childhood
so thank you very much for
50 minutes of therapy we i was going to
say this would cost we should be being
paid
so i was exactly i was like i realized
um the i grew up with
am i i'm not trying to be disparaging my
parents um
but they definitely were like what can i
take what can i take what can i take and
our house was always a pharmacy
it was it like literally every day my
parents would mix bc powder
which was an analgesic and and um
potent kind of like a headache medicine
and they would mix that with
you know whatever pill they were being
told that they needed to take right
there
and they went through all of the
designer pharmaceuticals uh as soon as
it was out they were taking it
and it was not recreational it was
therapeutic they were like i'm trying to
cure what it
whatever it is the the problem that i
have but i watched as it never
met the thing and i watched as it became
a
they were addicted to it it was it was
there was never a day that was spent
without
having one of those things instead of
pouring a bourbon it was pouring a bc
powder and whatever
cocktail of drugs so i
just so i'm clear are you saying actual
like you like especially narcotics you
can develop chemical dependencies on
medication no differently than
than any other drug for sure but medical
corporations can be evil
right like oxycontin i doubt it
is my opinion based on my assumptions
and information i have seen
because i assume that's a very litigious
company that that you know
there are are you a doctor mike are you
a doctor they're illegal there are
definitely cases where
corporations have you know sold medicine
and
the profit motive has surpassed the oh
my god yeah in the u.s
like i'm layering that so heavily with
sarcasm because i've been so many cases
about that where it's almost
like it's disgusting like how much
they've inflated medicine prices for
very basic needs and just the simple
business
of hey we we really believe in this work
i've seen the reps come through the
doctor's office where it's like for
every one of these prescriptions you
fill we're not going to give you money
for it
because can i recommend socialized
medicine
dude at this point
it's great you never have to worry you
you have a science-led
process by which drugs are worked out
and we all get them for free
the hard switch well that's actually
factually wrong we have to say like
oh i know i have to pay 10 quid
sometimes for a specific no no no
the cost is amortized across the cost as
well is paid by
taxes of course yes i i i'm not a fan of
the equation
the equation of many based on their
ability to pay rather than on how
unhealthy or
sick they are fair fair i i i i i think
that that's a whole
subject to unpack and i and i have very
much a uh personally a work in progress
i'm sorry i'm completely derailed troy
should be allowed to go back to where he
was because i just well actually i was
in the middle east i was in the middle
of asking
i was mid question for troy uh when you
talked about your parents
addiction i was asking are we talking
about a a literal like like the
oxycontin example that mike brings up or
are we just talking to
someone who became like like a
hypochondriac that just
always thinks something's wrong and
always needs to be feeding
the treatment of that even though it's
not the same thing as a chemical
addiction
right and i i also to kind of further
that point
i that's a question
i'm i was just curious when you refer to
your parents as being addicted
if it was to a literal medication or if
it was just the idea of treating
something is like inherently addicting i
don't
know i know that that's my business it's
kind of an invasive question to ask you
but
but i'm just curious look at that i'm an
open book
um the it's kind of i knew i knew about
prozac i knew about xanax i knew about
uh zoloft but when they when they first
came out like i was the hipster of that
not because i took them but because i
was i was in they were in my house
i had a doctor that put me in life
there's a cell on the on the schoolyard
uh i i uh my the same doctor that my
father had
said you have problems with with feeling
these things here take this pill
and i took it for a week and i didn't
give a [ __ ] about anything
anything i was like i realized after the
week i went
i don't care there's no
ambition no driving it's just level it
wasn't that i was happy
it wasn't that i was sad i was just like
i was blissfully ambivalent and i i
need to kids out with some of this stuff
it is
so i don't know if my parents were
addicted to the behavior to the
treatment
i myself there are no known
um chemical dependencies or addict
addiction to cannabis
but i know for me i went a
year where every night is like well i
need to make sure that i go to sleep
and so i would smoke a bowl or i would
you know
somehow do something to where cannabis
became my night cap we tell
ourselves stories that can be very
convincing to ourselves
uh that you don't need you don't need
the sort of like biochemical process of
addiction to become
addicted to something because you've
you've just told yourself i need this to
fall asleep
well you know my body also can
biochemically addict itself to whatever
anyway on certain so i think there's i
think
i think i'm right that that's where the
science is right now is is ultimately
the
you can become addicted to most things
that
your body can do can will develop its
own uh dependencies which is where you
get things dependencies
yeah really basic stuff like i have
chocolate once and i will want chocolate
every day after that and i can go months
without it not want it but i have it one
time and i'm like i need more chocolate
i need more working
there's endorphins that your body
releases when you work out and there's
people that are become addicted to the
gym
yeah i think that addictive behavior is
something that we absolutely impact
the reason why i put this forth is i
fully wholly admit
that i have by and large a negative view
on medicine i will suffer through i'm
not in the same position that elon is in
i will suffer through a headache um or
drink water or do
anything else besides taking a pill
because for me and my own baggage
and my own reasons i don't like chinese
experiences you're talking well i think
i'm generally the same
i would prefer not to take a pill if i
can avoid taking a pill but if i'm in
pain i'm gonna do it but i hate the way
i feel when i'm on painkillers so i'll
try and
reduce it as much as i can and i don't
know many
people really at all who are like super
pro like just give me a pill
give me that ibuprofen let's do this
i i do know those people it's like a
little bit of a headache i'm gonna take
this
they keep them and that by the way i'm
not in any way maligning disparaging
those people at all
it's it's i i fully own that is my as
as with everything i think in life we
are coming from this
as austin said we're telling our this
story from our personal experiences our
interests different
judgment it's just just how you feel but
i do
think that if if uh
austin pointing out the difference
between um
medicine and treatment so maybe it's not
that acupuncture like i personally i
could tell you is like dude i felt
[ __ ] different after going to that
acupuncturist i was like
i didn't know what this was going to be
that's not
medicine if you go if you use treatment
if before you go into that appointment
neither is psychotherapy but for that
matter too by the way quit
if you are completely committed
to the idea if your brain on even on a
subconscious level
fully believes that this acupuncture is
going to help you
the odds that it will are vastly higher
that's just the nature of psychosomatic
interactions even the process
so the other thing that's really
interesting which builds on what
austin's saying is
actually any procedural thing this has
been found out several times is the
placebo the easiest way to make the
placebo effect more effective
is to welcome you into a room give you a
receptionist to talk to
they've got a big form with a pen and
they go oh yes sir you're in room three
and you go there we the ritual of like
oh i'm in a doctor's office
same reason that we put loading bars in
games that lie to you all the time
because you have that that sense of
someone has this under control
and they're going to take care of me as
a massive placebo much more than just
giving you the pill if we give you the
placebo pill
it's a good show and tell you it's
medicine it will often work
if we walk you through the kind of the
the disney theme park queue
of like let's take you to the room let's
do this oh here's the doctor the doctor
has a well groomed beard and looks kind
of
knowledgeable and you know and goes
through all of this process
that's what can enhance it and and even
if you go in and you're like i'm
open-minded in the same way as no one
believes advertising works on them but
advertising works on all of us it's the
same kind of vibe like you go in with
you know you're they're building uh any
processes building that thing and yeah
where you get into the interesting
ethical and moral thing of is
if the trick works should you get a
refund for the magic show do you know
what i mean like and i i can kind of
relate to that
where i get concerned is when these
things are presented as alternatives to
actual medicine there i'm with you a
hundred percent yeah yeah and so this is
like
there's a anybody that is into this
conversation
uh darren brown miracle um is
is a wonderful if you it literally it is
it is the um matinee version
of like presented in the best possible
way of this conversation
including faith healers speaking in
tongues alternative medicines all those
things and also
uh podcast listeners um oh no ross and
kerry it's really good if you're not
listening
owner ross and kerry they they do um
they're two skeptics they do
uh investigation so they'll go and join
scientology for five episodes
or they'll go and learn at the moment
they're learning how to exercise people
and they're in the training program for
exorcism
like or even mythbusters are kind of in
that category i'm into it i
i believe this uh there's a um
example on one of those nerdy shows that
i watched but they said if you could
represent
film or if you could represent the
spectrum of light as film strip
um 35 millimeter film strip it would
stretch from la
to san francisco or something like that
and what the human humanized capable of
seeing
would fit on a single frame it's like
that the spectrum of light that we're
able to
see i don't think me and the line that
we're doing
it depends on your scale anything could
be bigger but you're it's relative
you're saying
yeah so the reason why i i bring up that
example is i go
there's a lot of [ __ ] that i can't see
there's a lot of [ __ ] that i don't know
there's a lot of [ __ ] that i'm
constantly learning about and i love
that example in thor where he says what
you call science we call magic
um and so it's it's this borderline
semantical
argument except for the fact that
lives could depend upon it i don't
believe that anybody should go
i reject this in favor of this
i believe it's a also and
uh you can you can have as many people
blow
incense into your face as possible like
as long as you also go to a doctor like
i agree completely with you
yeah yeah that's fine but i do worry
that there's an erosive effect i worry
that and this is this is a slippery
slope argument which is never a good
place to go rhetorically
but i do worry that if we open the door
to like
this is an additional treatment you you
inevitably there's going to be some
people along the way who go
well i don't like going to the doctor
but the person who does my
alternative therapy is friendlier and i
like them more i'll skip the doctor this
week i do worry about the kind of
a potential transition that we have by
by not acknowledging this as an
entertainment product and calling it
medicine
but if it has results does it matter if
it has results
it won't make you better it might like
the placebo effects
i i think i'm right now i'm not excited
about that effect
if it had an effect it would be
available for you at your local hospital
if it was really if it was real and
scientifically endorsed i mean i guess
my situation with migraines
why wouldn't you if you could sell
acupuncture as a process that would
actually cure you of any illness or any
problem they do it at hospitals i agree
i hear what you're saying but we've done
that now with cannabis
so cannabis yes well there's so what's
interesting with cbd is it's a specific
is that's what happens actually it's a
really good example what i'm talking
about is once you acknowledge the
medicinal
potential of an alternative thing and
then you test it and you find out oh
[ __ ] cannabis does help people
what cbd is is an act extraction of the
aspect that helps you
that's my understanding at least away
from the stuff which gets you high right
like cbd won't get you high
right there's no thc there's there's
it's it's
but this is what i'm talking about is
the industrialization of a process where
they go
okay let's do the science let's find out
why this why do people who are smoking
cannabis feel better oh it's because of
this this and this how do we turn how do
we make that more potent how do we make
it cheaper to produce
how do we make it safe for all of these
kind of questions and that's where you
get to medicine
so how long did it take us for us to do
that
um between cannabis is popular adoption
in western culture to that
you're looking at i know that we the
weed legalization
conversation dates back to like in terms
of public discourse like the 50s right
so maybe like
17 no no even before then so the reason
why tobacco yes
we'd know is because by the way behind
the scenes the main voice arguing for
the legalization for cannabis there's so
much stuff exactly
like freedom like from the 60s
but the reason why the the and i'm
talking about smoking pot is a medicine
i'm saying that the medicinal purposes
of cbd oil that we are now seeing and
there's a lot of people who say it's
[ __ ] too but
the science doesn't play with those
people right so but they're what i'm
saying is like
this probably putting putting it through
as you say the industrialization the
process of that
whereas before the litigious argument
for it was
by and large being propagated by tobacco
farmers
so it was it wasn't the the the medical
benefits and the properties of cbd or
or marijuana or cannabis or whatever
never changed it's just that
we were slow to adopt it so what i'm
saying is it could very well be
holy [ __ ] we used to give pills to
people you know to people for this
when all we needed to do is stick a
needle in them so the difference in your
argument there is there were doctors
saying that
we did this from the point where there
were
scientists who were doing the research
well they've done research there's been
a lot of research into acupuncture and
all of it has proven it to have zero
effect because sticking a needle on your
right i recommend you're getting
something to me but i will say that like
what they have recommended because i
vomit up pills is suppositories and i'm
like but i don't
want to do that so bite
i am trying other stuff like if i could
not do that that would be great
so it's cbd oil that was not recommended
by a doctor that's recommended by other
people who've had migraines
i guess the problem i have and the
concern i have is if they if it wasn't
cbd oil if they just said to you
suppository's the way to go and then
you'd also go on well i don't like that
but like maybe i can try this
alternative therapy that doesn't
actually work then potentially if it was
this
if this was in any way a
life-threatening kind of situation oh
for sure you would be less likely to
take the suppository which says it is
it assumes a lot about medicine right
it's it's
the notion of like if it's not medicine
it's not good it assumes a lot of that
as opposed to
it's not been proven by the scientific
method to make people better it's not
good
i don't know it's not good yeah it's
really not because you're effective
ineffective in effectiveness or
potentially so effective
right but what i guess what it more
likely and effective than effective i
agree
yeah we used to prescribe cocaine heroin
oxycontin worked as well that's the
thing right
medicine has been wrong before though
too medicine's wrong science is a
process and
things get better what doesn't that's
existed for thousands of years that
doesn't work
doesn't suddenly then get found to work
no one's going to do a study and go
[ __ ] guys acupuncture is real so it
didn't work for me
it worked if it worked for you it worked
on a placebo level and
god bless you if that worked for you i'm
not i'm not knocking you as an
individual doing it
where i have concerns is an
institutional level that we no no no no
what i'm talking about it's not a
placebo level it is
okay the science would imply it is
anyway okay so if i look at a muscle and
a muscle has a knot in it right which is
a collection of
toxins or whatever it is and a needle
goes
dunk right there and it goes so that's a
massage is not placebo massage and
physiotherapy have been found through
research
to improve so actually pressure on and
not
does stop the knot from existing but
that's acupuncture
no acupuncture sticking a needle into
someone that's what i'm saying i had
another that's the thing is when it's
these processes when they when they do
these studies
they'll go they they will and it's
double i i'm this is where i'm
i need to be very careful and say the
wrong thing double blinds and tests like
that they will go
okay does acupuncture have an effect
over massage does the needle going into
your skin
actually change the outcome because yes
applying pressure to a knot
will relieve that tension and will will
improve that's why
sports massage is actually
scientifically proven and demonstrated
in large part i think there's as always
there's kind of
weird sidebars but like there's there is
there is evidence of that
no one has ever found out no one has
ever scientifically demonstrated
or tested or proven the hypothesis by
testing that sticking a needle in
someone
makes them better especially in the
acupuncture way obviously if that needle
is connected to a syringe that has
medicine in it
it's very effective also there's the
added challenge of the fact that
everything that i know about acupuncture
is um that the claims are often
very uh vague for example troy you used
the word toxins which is one of those
that's one of those kind of terms that
that has no actual meaningful definition
in medicine
to say oh my you know let's flush the
toxins from the body it's like well what
what's the actual like molecular
composition of what you're talking about
uh
like because everything is going to end
up coming down to specifics you know you
get rid of this by doing that you get
rid of this
this is a thing you don't actually want
to get rid of but if you have too much
of it it's
detrimental to the working that's what
it is supposed to actually be a
antigenic poison or venom of a plant or
animal origin so we do use that word
completely incorrectly most of the time
also i have to go oh [ __ ] should i just
let you guys continue to have this
conversation because i could just keep
recording
it's about the four of us but i have
work
just real quick mike are you are you
okay
the royal family i feel is heavily
disrupted and i just want to make sure
on a personal level you're surviving it
okay
i think i think it sucks that we have a
royal family and
it's awful that they're institutionally
allowed to bully what who could imagine
them
seems like a decent human being like who
would have thought that's the thing
that's the thing that's hilarious is the
reason this new story has got
the legs it has i only brought you up
for the laugh
everyone everyone knows all of these
stories
are or everyone presumes myself included
and i would not make a
final statement on this but everyone
presumes these stories are absolutely
true because
it would be amazing it would be the most
surprising thing in the world
if the royal family were the only rich
people in
the uk who weren't racist who've also
selected the only arrows
to marry their own cousins to avoid
letting anyone else in the family
a literal embodiment of white rich
supremacy
by birth birth i mean the whole notion
of that whole notion of
blood needing to be pure is kind of what
royalty like by definition
means yeah and and a family
of a family who the last person who
abdicated and i don't think harry has
abdicate because technically he can't
because he wasn't in line to the throne
but
or he's obviously he is no he's not he's
off the line now because it's good
anyway
um the um i i wish i didn't have bits in
my brain that were full of this
bollocks because it's just it's not the
royal family is just this joke that all
of us have really committed to and it's
really annoying
but i love how in america we all watch
it like it's days of our lives and we're
like oh my god i can't believe what
happened today
the problem is it's
like the class system in the uk is
horrific and they are
they are the kind of the agreed-upon
delusion that backs up the whole system
and they they
shouldn't they shouldn't be there they
should the people i'm sure there's good
people in the royal family there's bad
people in the royal family
but let them just be people let them go
and have jobs and
do things and on that note
my taxes go on the royals it's not fair
but also on medicine
all right thank you